fox news alert more protests in
jerusalem calling for israeli prime
minister benjamin netanyahu to resign
[Music]
there have been five demonstrations in
the last week another one is scheduled
for tonight in front of the prime
minister's home
trey yangst is there now and he joins us
live trey
[Music]
melissa good morning thousands of people
are expected to gather here this evening
in jerusalem in front of the house of
israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu
you can see many israelis have already
shown up police are trying to separate
the two sides the people that you are
looking at right now
are against the israeli prime minister
and they are
frustrated about the government's
handling of the kobit 19 outbreak
on the other side of the location we are
standing
you've got pro israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu
protesters now on tuesday here at this
site at least 34 people were arrested
during similar protests
and clashes more than 20 of israelis are
currently
unemployed right now as a result of the
economic fallout from coronavirus
and the prime minister has been heavily
criticized for not coming up with a
better plan to help those who are out of
a job
now israel successfully locked down and
beat their first wave of
covid19 before rapidly reopening schools
and businesses this led the country into
a far worse second wave
that has seen more than 50 000 total
cases of kobit 19.
now overnight the prime minister did
appoint a coronavirus czar
who was the ceo of one of israel's
largest hospitals
but this is not calming much of the
tension here we even saw this morning a
tweet from israel's president
ruby rivlin calling on all parties
within the government
to come together and cut it out he said
that there is no plan currently and as
cases for covet 19
continue to rise here in israel you can
sense the frustration outside of the
prime minister's house
police tonight hoping this remains
peaceful melissa
trey yingst thank you